malaysia's acting Transport Minister
said the shift in focus does not mean
the debris spotted in earlier satellite
images wasn't from the loss plane the
Australian authorities have indicated
that they have shifted the search area
approximately 1,100 kilometres to the
north east because of ocean drift this
new search area could still be
consistent with the potential objects
identified by various satellite images
over the past week the minister
explained that new analysis of radar
data had shown the plane may not have
flown as far as previously thought
investigators say the planes higher
flight speed would mean it ran out of
fuel earlier than previously assumed
leading them to shift the search area
closer to flight 370's takeoff point in
kuala lumpar as Australian and u.s.
planes took off from Perth Western
Australia to scan the new search area
Australian authorities warned the search
could still take some time the new area
is about the size of Poland meanwhile
the wait for information goes on for the
families of those on board in the
Malaysian capital prayers were held in
remembrance of those lost being fire Chi
mh370 and what that nostalgia for the
Dickinson family
that's all until more information comes
in praying is just about all the victims
families and friends can do